智能体能帮你提速，省下大量工作，还能处理翻译、改尺寸这类任务。但我们坚信设计中人的因素极其重要，所以我们在努力
打造一个让人能和智能体高效协作的工具。用Cloud Design生成的东西确实诱人，但我觉得那并不能让你脱颖而出。设计是巨大的
差异化优势。看看过去一二十年那些伟大的公司，几乎无一例外都拥有顶尖的设计。所以我认为，如果你想成为那样真正卓越的公司，就必须在设计上倾注心力
确保自己与众不同。
>> 今天，我很高兴请到Paper的创始人Steven Haney。Paper是一款AI原生的设计工具，已经在设计界掀起浪潮。我们YC内部已经大量使用Paper来做各类设计工作，
我很期待他向大家展示这款产品的运作方式。Steven，非常感谢你的到来。
>> 能来这儿是我的荣幸。我经常看这个节目，所以能上节目真的非常非常开心。谢谢你的邀请。
>> 也许先跟大家介绍一下Paper是什么吧。
>> 好的，Paper是一款设计工具，而且是一款智能体原生的设计工具。这意味着我们用HTML和CSS作为实际的渲染引擎，这让智能体用起来非常轻松，因为它们对HTML和CSS非常熟悉。
而在过去，很多设计工具都采用自定义渲染引擎，这对智能体来说难度更大。结果就是token消耗更高、速度更慢、准确率更低。而我们用Paper构建的
本质上是一个团队，目前大约12个人，全是设计师和工程师。我们是出于对设计的热爱而起步的，现在只是想为这个新时代打造出最好的设计工具。
>> 难以想象你们只有12个人，因为我总听到大家在谈论你们，尤其是很多创始人，他们都在选用自己心仪的设计工具，并长期使用，
而且从一开始他们自己就是AI原生的，自然也会寻找AI原生工具。
>> 绝对如此。
>> 所以，不妨谈谈你创建Paper的灵感来源，以及为什么现有的一些工具对你来说不够好？
>> 这确实是源于对设计的热爱。如我所说，我起初是独立创业者，这其实是一个持续下去的副业项目。有几个月我甚至怀疑：会有人在意Paper吗？
后来发现，哦，原来大家确实在意，这真是太好了，它真的火了。这是我无论如何都会去做的事情，是我本来就要做的事。我坚信创业就该这样，你应该去
做你注定要做的事，你应当找到创始人与市场契合的点。对我来说，这里就是我契合度最高的地方，因为我热爱为创意工作者打造工具。这件事
让我每天醒来，都觉得自己不会在做创意工具时倒霉。所以这优先于市场、竞争对手等一切。然后环顾四周，心想：天哪，
如今的设计界，不提Figma都不行。他们为设计行业做出了巨大贡献。现在他们公司规模庞大，在企业客户中做得非常成功。
于是我们在想，或许该有个新工具是专注服务设计师的，能真正投入大量时间应对AI智能体带来的巨变。我们能不能做出一个智能体原生、
基于HTML和CSS的下一代工具？这就是我们努力的方向，目前看来进展不错。
>> AI原生、智能体原生的设计工具，具体意味着什么？
>> 关键在底层技术。用HTML和CSS做渲染引擎，我们其实是为了优化设计师与开发者的交接。我们想：如果设计师能在这个无束缚的系统中工作，
感觉像Figma或Sketch，但实际上底层是HTML——他们无需知道这一点。那样交接会很顺利。结果发现，既然人机交接顺畅了，智能体交接也不会差，因为智能体
代理能理解HTML和CSS，这些都在它们的训练数据里。所以，当你让代理处理Paper文件时，它实际上就是直接读取CSS。代理完全知道怎么处理。你基本上是在尝试
用可视化界面扩展代理。有时候我觉得Paper是设计工具，但它也是代理的可视化界面。我们看到销售、工程师、各种人都在用，因为提示不一定是最好的输入方式
有时候你想拖拽、绘制，直接操作会更快。
是的，这很有意思，因为随着软件构建变得越来越容易，弄清楚要构建什么以及如何获得灵感似乎成了最棘手的问题之一，也是最大的瓶颈之一。
你觉得如何用Paper来解决创意流程中的这一部分？
我们看到正在创建的软件比以往任何时候都多，工程团队现在进展神速。我不知道你怎么想，但我没觉得软件变得更好了。过去六个月里，我没有遇到一款让我惊艳的软件。
过去六个月里，我没有遇到一款让我惊艳的软件。所以对我们来说很重要，我从小就热爱软件，就像软件粉丝一样。我喜欢打造伟大的软件。你能给我的最好赞美就是Paper是真正出色的软件。
所以我希望世界上有更多这样的软件，我想帮助设计师和有品味的人跟上所有正在创建的软件的步伐。给他们一个能与提示和代理速度同步的工具，而不是被拖进IDE或原型工具，但还能以更快的速度做传统设计工作，我觉得这非常重要。
给他们一个能与提示和代理速度同步的工具，而不是被拖进IDE或原型工具，但还能以更快的速度做传统设计工作，我觉得这非常重要。
我很想看个演示。你能给我们展示一下它是怎么运作的吗？
好，我们直接开始。这是一个非常熟悉的界面，如果你用过画布工具的话。有时候我喜欢从视觉的东西开始。因为我们基本上用浏览器来渲染，所以我们也能很容易地渲染着色器。着色器就是我们构建的WebGL动画。
这些着色器很容易。着色器基本上就是我们构建的WebGL动画。这叫做Paper shaders，是我们整理的一个库。完全开源，你可以随意使用。着色器非常有趣，品牌设计师们很喜欢，因为你可以得到各种不同的外观。
着色器非常有趣，品牌设计师们很喜欢，因为你可以得到各种不同的外观。这只是一个着色器，但设置不同。所以你可以做各种事情。我知道在YC，你们一直在用
我们一直在用这些。我们很喜欢。我觉得，对我们来说，而且我猜对很多人来说，这可能是他们第一次接触Paper。这感觉很现代、很前沿，一年前做起来会很困难。
一年前做起来会很困难，而你们让它变得非常简单，并且很原生地集成到产品中，以至于它到处都在出现，因为现在太容易做到了，对吧？
那是我们的希望之一，我们能否让设计师更容易使用这些？因为如果你是一名设计师，整天在使用传统设计工具，你想创建一个着色器效果，你想描述AI加载状态如何工作，我一直听到的就是，我需要为AI做加载状态，怎么做呢？
你需要为AI做加载状态，怎么做呢？所以我们想，最好能提供这些可自定义的动画效果，不仅能用现成的，还能进去调整，让它们成为你自己的，你可以做各种酷炫的事情。
你不仅能用现成的，还能进去调整，让它们成为你自己的，你可以做各种酷炫的事情。当然，你可以使用混合模式来创建组合。
你可以使用混合模式来创建组合。而且，有些更微妙的效果也很受欢迎。比如半色调网点。你可以把其他东西拉进效果里。比如把神经噪声拉进半色调网点。
你可以尝试不同的东西，得到不同的效果。我们花了很多时间，我们研究了真实的纸张，模拟物理效果的随机性，然后尝试在代码中建模。所以我觉得我们的着色器库能脱颖而出，其中一个原因是我们竭尽全力做到最好。
所以品牌设计师们真的很喜欢这个。比如一个例子是Quarter，不知道你们知不知道Quarter海报。这些海报真的很酷，是这个团队做的，好像是做财报的。他们现在很多都用Paper来做，因为他们能很快得到那种复古的感觉。
Quarter海报，他们现在很多都用Paper来做，因为他们能很快得到那种复古的感觉。所以我很喜欢他们的作品，真的很酷，我很荣幸他们用Paper来做海报。
他们能很快得到那种复古的感觉。所以我很喜欢他们的作品，真的很酷，我很荣幸他们用Paper来做这些海报。
是的，真的很酷。我们用它来为创业学校做东西，YC的设计负责人Ev实际上用YC品牌创作了定制的动画着色器，上面有人名，还有门票，当人们被录取时，你可以玩这些动画，然后发给他们。这对接收者来说是一种很棒的体验，感觉非常贴心、用心，设计感十足。
当人们被录取时，你可以玩这些动画，然后发给他们。这对接收者来说是一种很棒的体验，感觉非常贴心、用心，设计感十足。而且还能创造出非常...
具有分享性，人们愿意分享出去，这有助于口碑传播，而这同样得益于设计和着色器的效果。
这是一种非常快速的方式来提升视觉效果，让它更特别一些。所以，着色器在品牌设计师中非常受欢迎。另外，Paper 还有一个不太为人知的功能，我们其实有一个很棒
图像生成库，你可以同时使用各种模型。比如，我们生成一个沉思的人望着月亮的插图。可以想象，这是为了品牌作品或者你正在做的任何东西。而且这个
会同时使用四种不同的模型，你可以快速探索你需要的各种插图的可能性空间。
这太酷了。是的，我看到你设置成了“混合包”。是不是就是这个功能让你同时得到四个结果？
如果你想的话，你可以选择某个特定模型。它们各有优缺点，或者你可以用“混合包”，我们会轮换里面的模型，因为新模型不断涌现。
它就能让你快速探索，而且你可以提供输入。比如，我可以把这个着色器复制为一张图片，然后把它喂进去，说“请让这张图更鲜艳一些”，这样你
就能结合这些东西，实现各种不同的工作流程，非常快速地创作出很酷的图形。嗯，同样是这个思路，你还可以进行矢量化。你可以做颜色提取，咱们试试这个。
智能体生成了一张非常五彩斑斓的作品，我可以提取其中的颜色，它会自动提取出来，这样我就能快速地用这种方法探索想法。嗯，还能生成新的纹理之类的。所以这基本上就是 Paper 在品牌
这一块的内容，主要是图形设计。我们发现，所有的设计师都需要制作品牌素材。他们需要制作社交媒体帖子之类的各种内容。
这也很有意思，因为你知道，我觉得很多人用 Figma 并且把它看作是产品设计工具。
嗯。
而且它确实可以做很多品牌设计的元素，但它一开始并不那么侧重这个。看起来你们既能做产品设计，又有这些非常酷的工具来做品牌设计的工作。
是的。
还有平面设计，你知道，传统上我觉得在很多这些工具里，平面设计是比较难做的。
是的，这是我们价值观的一部分。我们两者都喜欢，你知道吗？所以，我觉得产品设计非常有趣，但我们也会一直保留品牌设计和图形设计。说实话，我们对着色器的想法是：
我们花了——这其实是我们的营销预算。我们不把这看作是产品开发。我们想的是，与其买广告，不如为世界打造一个有用的库，把精力和资金投入到建设着色器库上。这确实得到了很多关注，
而且效果很好。同样地，我们还开发了一款新字体，叫 Paper Mono，我们准备推出它，我为此感到非常自豪。它真的非常非常好。嗯，我们发现没有一款等宽字体，是那种
万金油式的，既能用于营销，又能用于编码。大多数都是为终端设计的。所以我们想要一款可以融入品牌设计的字体，于是我们做了 Paper Mono。它将在几周后发布。
这对我们来说就是营销。也就是说，与其买广告，不如打造一款字体。这对世界更好，对吧？所以，YC 的 Eva 前几天晚上在纽约的一个晚宴上，遇到一个人穿着一件
印有 Paper Mono 的 T 恤，我觉得这太酷了。
因为这种 T 恤，全世界可能也就一百件吧。
是啊，怎么才能得到一件呢？嗯，我们可以给你弄一件。我们会给你寄过去。
（笑声）
我们想开一个周边商店，就是 Paper 的周边店。但是这就是 Paper Mono。我们很快就会推出一个很棒的迷你网站。我们在数字的可读性上花了很多功夫，因为那是...
很多等宽字体在这方面都做不好。我们觉得这个字体非常清晰、非常实用。所以我们真的很兴奋，对吧？这太有趣了。我们能做这些事情，基本上也算是
我们营销的一部分。
>> 你提到这个产品最初是为了解决设计到开发的交接问题。给我们展示一下你们是怎么在产品里实现的。
>> 好的，是的。最初是这样的：“嘿，这是代码。这实际上是一个React组件。为什么不让你直接把它复制成React组件呢？”所以我们现在看到的这个着色器，你可以右键点击，然后复制成React组件。
当你粘贴的时候，你会得到我们正在看的这段代码。所以这是一种非常快捷的方式，就像说：“嘿，设计师们做了这个很酷的动画，他们已经把它调得很完美了。他们是设计师，对吧？”那就让他们直接复制出来并发布吧。我们已经在网上看到这些组件到处都是。人们在分享这些React组件。
设计师，对吧？让他们直接复制并发布。我们已经看到这些在网上到处都有。人们发布这些React组件。但还不止于此。你在Paper里看到的任何东西都是代码。
这个框里面有这个盒子，这本身就是代码。它基本上就是一个网站了。你可以把它复制成Tailwind，或者复制成React，然后直接提取代码。这就是我们开始的地方。那已经
挺不错的了。我们已经看到有一些人在使用它。然后呢，是去年12月，2025年12月，
>> Claude code爆发了。
>> 我没想到设计师会去用终端。我从没想过我们会看到这样的事。但我们确实看到了。所以那一刻我们就在想：“天哪，我们必须上桌面端了。”那时候，
我们还没有桌面应用。所以就想：“天哪，我们必须上桌面端了。那里才是现在发生事情的地方。本地代码库，设计师有代码库，他们在学GitHub。让我们成为这次爆发的一部分。”
我们觉得这差不多就是新的智能体技术栈。我的意思是，你看，我有Cursor，我有Claude code，你有多个智能体。你有Paper作为一种与智能体视觉交流的方式。然后，
可能你还有GitHub或者代码评审。这就是我们看到建设者现在使用的工具。我是说，你看到的也是这样吗？比如最新的YC批次？
>> 是的，我们看到的很多就是这样。我们甚至看到很多这样的功能被整合到单个应用里。我们的朋友在Conductor，你可以直接推送代码、合并代码，做所有你需要的事情。就是这样。
>> 是的，我也开着Conductor。是啊。
>> 直接就在应用里。所以，越来越多这样的功能被整合到应用里，而不是作为技术栈中的多个独立应用。
>> 我们也看到了这一点。而且Conductor和Paper现在是这种配对，社区里很多人同时使用这两个。我觉得这太酷了。我喜欢Conductor。很棒的产品。但我们看到Claude code爆发了，就想，
让我们上桌面端吧。我们在我们的桌面应用里内置了一个MTP服务器，我给你演示一下它能做的一些事情。我们用Conductor来做这个演示吧。为什么不呢？我就说：“嘿，Conductor，在Paper里请
做一个小的测试框架，向YC打个招呼。”我给你们看看它在做什么。我们会进入更复杂的案例，但只是给你展示一下基本的技术是怎么工作的。当智能体使用Paper的MTP时，我们会把它放在屏幕的右半部分，
我们给它工具调用来做像这样的：“嘿，有哪些字体可用？这个页面的基本设置是什么？”然后它真的运行工具，比如写HTML。这真的是，嗯，它是JSON格式，但实际上它是在给我们发送HTML。
>> 嗯哼。
>> 而Paper引擎可以直接处理HTML。它知道怎么处理。这里没有转换。智能体写HTML，Paper能渲染HTML，你不必在格式之间来回切换。
这样做能节省你的tokens。让运行速度更快，并且减少奇怪的幻觉。这真的是我们腾飞的时刻，因为人们在做设计转代码，也在做代码转设计。我再给你
举一个Cursor里的例子。这是我们实际的Paper代码库，我就说：“嘿，你能把那个colors.css放到Paper画布上作为样式指南吗？”所以这是我们实际的CSS文件，来自Paper代码库，不是那个
产品本身。Cursor会获取它然后渲染到画布上。我们看到很多人在做代码库审计，看看有什么。你可以做组件架构，要求画图。而且它
实际上，这不过是把设计工具融入到了整个技术栈里。我们习惯了设计工具被放在一边，对吧？
而且它和开发之间有一道墙。现在设计工具变成了整个技术栈的一部分。
对，这就是我们的目标。
是的，在交接过程中，一直有个问题就是设计师设计好了，交给开发，但最终可能不会按照设计师在画布上的原始意图去实现和发布。
你知道，就是设计师在设计时想要的样子。
嗯。
或者即使实现了，代码演进后也会和设计脱节，永远不会同步回去。那么，什么才是真正的源？好在代码就是源，两个系统都能在那份代码上协作。
代码是唯一事实来源，两个系统都能在这份代码基础上操作。
没错，我们看到很多团队维护着两套设计系统。
是啊。
要保持它们同步，简直是不可能完成的任务，维护成本太高，而且容易出错。所以，我们看到新公司，那些更智能的构建者，都把代码库当成唯一事实来源。
那些更智能的构建者，就是他们开始把代码库作为唯一事实来源。
嗯哼。
其实Paper里还没有组件，这是常被抱怨的，大家很想要组件，我们也正在做。但你并不需要它们，因为你的代码库是唯一的，你可以随时调用需要的东西。我们还更进一步，做了个Chrome扩展，能抓取你的线上网站，直接复制到Paper画布上，这样从用户所见出发，在上面迭代，特别好用。
需要什么就可以直接调用什么。而且，我们还更进一步，做了个Chrome扩展，能抓取你的线上网站到Paper画布中，这样从用户所见出发，在上面迭代优化。
从用户所见出发，在此之上构建和迭代。
也许这是个好的过渡。我们要不要看看用户提交的网站，然后我很想用那个功能，把一些拉进Paper里做些调整，看看能不能实时编辑，来改进一些网站？
试着去改进这些网站。
我太乐意了，这总是我最喜欢的环节。
好。
[笑声]
太好了，我们开始吧。第一个是Legion Health，精神科诊疗低至$0，保险覆盖，线上管理多动症、抑郁、焦虑、双相情感障碍等。我不确定，第一眼看到，顶部有个小药丸，这让我觉得可能是那种“氛围编程”做出来的，因为风格太像智能体批量生成的那种了。
我一看这，上面有个小药丸，就感觉这像是那种“氛围编程”搞出来的，因为它和那种智能体生成的风格太像了。
确实有那种打磨细节的问题。比如这些小细节，像这些区块间有间隙，药丸设计很通用。不过总体上，我能理解它的价值主张。
嗯哼。
看起来非常清楚，我觉得这点很棒。
设计很大一部分在于，你能不能理解正在发生什么？
右边显示了这样的好处，
在某个领域里非常开心之类的，[笑声] 我猜。
对，你过着很美好的生活。
嗯。
我觉得这些部分都还不错。但问题在于，你知道，把设计打磨得更精细一点，真的能帮助品牌看起来更认真、更高端，也更值得信赖一些。
对。
嗯，这个看起来，你知道，我现在不确定是否信任这个品牌。而这是一个需要建立信任的领域，对吧？
对，那你看到这个的时候，是什么让你不信任它？
有些设计元素，比如对齐方式、对比度的选择。它们感觉像是随便做的，或者有人没怎么用心，那你的大脑就会想：还有哪些地方他们也没怎么用心？
另外一件事是，这肯定是个YC公司，但我没看到相关标识，我觉得把它标注出来会很好，
[笑声]
作为一种社会认同，
对。
或者证据。但这个东西还不错。我的意思是，这里有很多值得喜欢的地方。我只会建议你在细节和完成度上下点功夫。我给你看看Paper Snapshot。Paper Snapshot是一种从你实时网站上抓取内容的方式。这个
取代了截图。所以，我们就抓取这一段，因为我觉得这个可以拿来打磨一下。然后把它粘贴到Paper里。这些都是实时区域，对吧？这不是截图。这是真实的，你可以
进来编辑，还可以按住Alt键拖拽复制一份，等等。嗯，那我们就让智能体处理一下这个。我喜欢做的一件事是，直接让它生成几个变体。
嗯。
那我们就用，嗯，Conductor。嘿，Conductor。这是用GPT 5.5。你能在Paper里为我选的区域做三个新变体，重点放在工艺、对齐和对比度的选择上，以提升视觉效果吗？
你可以用很多提示词，但我发现其实简单的提示词就足够好了。
这什么特别厉害？有几个方面。第一，我喜欢这种直接生成一堆不同变体的概念。这是获得灵感最好的方式。有时候，你知道自己想要什么，
但又不完全清楚。这是一种很好的方式，可以让你看很多选项，然后说，我喜欢这个里面的那个，喜欢那个里面的那个。把它们结合起来，就能更快地取得更多进展，而不是陷入
创意枯竭。然后另一个很酷的地方是，你只需要说：“嘿，我在画布上选的那个东西
对，Paper。”
而且它知道那是什么。现在它就能着手去做了，这真的很强大。
我觉得我选错了。让我用YC卡来演示一下。
【笑声】
让我重新开始一下。这次用我选的。哦，我明白了，它用高清内容改掉了。其实，这正好可以展示我们的另一个功能。我们可以在这个画面上留个评论。
比如，写上“请给我做三个不同的版本，探索一下排版，让视觉效果更有冲击力。”而我会做的是，我先在Paper上留个评论：、
在Paper里留个评论
嗯嗯。
现在我就切换到智能体这边，说一句“请处理我在Paper里的评论。”只有一条。这也是一种方式，你可以想象，如果有一个大设计，你可以在里面留下所有反馈，然后直接让智能体去处理。
你留下所有反馈，然后就让智能体去处理。
对，就让它自己转去。
但我们看到很多人让它通宵运行。
他们会设置循环
嗯。
让智能体生成几百种不同的版本。这其实对我们来说是个挑战，比如要扩展服务器来应对这些工作，因为它实际做的工作比我想象的多得多。
这很酷。然后它们会进来筛选，比如“这个想法不错，那个也不错，让我把这些结合起来。”我觉得这种新的筛选和设计过程非常有趣。
想想这种场景真的很酷：你走进去，在工作上留下一堆评论，然后睡了，早上醒来，所有评论要么已经被处理，要么有大量变体等着你挑选。
它们就在那里等着你。
没错，我觉得这真的很酷。
这是一个新世界。
我发现它能做我知道但没想到的事情，因为我太忙了。所以某种程度上，它让我能分身，让我一天有更多时间，因为我可以把任务交给它，就像那些常规的，或者我实在没时间同时做的四件事；我就让智能体去处理。
那种更模板化的，或者我实在没时间同时做的四件事；我就让智能体去处理。
这是5.5版，它现在在处理想法。你会看到它迭代。它能截屏，所以它会注意到比如对齐问题，比如文字快碰到一起了。它会边跑边自己修正。
嗯，然后……
对，这很酷。
好，它其实已经给我一个版本了，但这里的对齐有点乱，它还在继续跑。所以它给你的不是一个最终结果，而是一个迭代过程，明白吧？
它的工作。是的，智能体在这方面也在不断进步。比如，我看到第一次它把文字放在卡片上，通常它会抓住这个问题并纠正它，或者如果没有，你可以直接，
你知道，告诉它嘿，纠正一下文字溢出。
嗯。
嗯，让我这样做。我们把字体设为适应，然后回到
指挥家。请处理任何文字溢出问题。我注意到的另一件事是模型总是在不断进步，它们有不同的优缺点。
嗯。
所以我经常用快速模型做演示，它们往往会犯更多错误。所以你知道，如果你真的在认真做，你可能会用前沿模型，那些模型会提供更好的性能。
是的，你最近常用哪些模型？
Fable 很棒，我觉得它在视觉审美上目前可能是最好的。
是的，它很慢，所以我不用它做演示。我其实常用 Cursor 的 Composer 2.5，它在速度和精度上都很不错，质量很好，很精准。5.5 也通常是个很好的平衡。
所以我会换来换去。如果我只是追求纯视觉，我会用 Fable 和 Anthropic 的模型。如果我需要精准或者有像“嘿，我有100个画板，需要逐步处理列表里的任务”这样的需求，我可能会选 Composer。它确实做得很精准，我发现 Cursor 是个很好的工具，它不会太懒，经常会启动子智能体来完成任务。所以我换来换去。这里它给了三种不同的
列表。”我可能会用 Composer。它做得很精准，Cursor 真是个很好的辅助工具，不会太懒，它会启动子智能体来做事。所以我换着用。它给了我三个不同的
想法，你知道吧？我认为从这儿出发，我通常会花更多时间来明确我到底想要什么，然后给模型更多方向。但我可能会开始分支，我会想，“哦，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个列表，实际上它很好读。”我喜欢这种卡片布局，突出一个卡片，旁边放其他小卡片，那样很好。我可能会开始分支。
我有点喜欢这个列表，那样很容易读。我觉得这种卡片布局其实不错。可以这样开始分支。我觉得厉害之处在于
你可以让五个智能体分别生成五个变体，然后找到一个真正适合你目标的。所以我会换着用。
我觉得有趣的是它能给你很多灵感和想法，然后你可以开始分支并深入探索。但设计仍然是模型在做，它仍然带有我们经常看到的模型产物的一些特征，无论好坏。那么，你在设计时，当你有了这些灵感，你会想，“对了，这个列表很有趣，我以前没想到，也许我想要
那些模型常见的设计痕迹。你如何在此基础上加入自己的风格，摆脱那种标准化输出呢？
去遵循那个灵感。”然后你如何把它变成自己的，摆脱模型常见的那些套路？
嗯，是的。我有些非常具体的规则可以分享。第一，模型喜欢粗体，它们倾向于使用粗体样式，实际上应该减少字体重量。你知道，粗体很有诱惑力，但尽量调到你能承受的最轻重量，那样视觉效果会奇迹般地变好。另一个问题是字体大小太多，模型喜欢用五种、六种、七种甚至八种不同的字号，尽量用三种。如果你
把字体调轻，设计看起来会好很多。另一个问题是字号过多，模型喜欢搞五六七八种字号，尽量精简到三种。如果
能减到三种，那么我们来快速试试这个。如果我们降到像500这样的字重，啊，那可能还是比需要的重。同样，这里这些字其实不需要加粗。这是明显的痕迹，上面这里，组织列表，黑色这么重。我们把字重调低，突然看起来更像设计了。
需要加粗。这是个典型的败笔，上面这个标题，组织列表，黑色这么重。让我们调轻它，突然看起来就更像设计了。
[笑声]
对，看起来更干净了。
更干净，更易接近。这儿也一样，黑色太重了，调轻它。这些都是非常简单的微调，可以进行。这里的对比度相当不错，很多情况下模型会搞砸对比度，所以我
这又是一个步骤。你可以确认一下，比如，文字是否清晰可读？
>> 对。
>> 嗯，这些小数字2、3、4，对我来说对比度有点太强了。我可能会把它们调淡一点，它们应该只是辅助元素。
>> 我直接删掉它们吗？我是说，那些模型喜欢添加数字或小图标之类的东西。是的，能直接删掉确实很酷，而且它会自动调整布局，不会留下空白。
而不是留个空位在那里。
>> 完全同意，完全同意。这其实就是这个工具的一个强大之处：Paper首先是一个设计工具，它是为人类设计的工具，碰巧对智能体也非常友好。这意味着你可以根据需求自定义任何东西。
你不受限于当前的模式，不需要重新提示。你可以直接介入并修改。所以，是的，百分之百同意。也许把那个也去掉。
我做的第一件事就是尽量把字体大小压缩到三种左右，然后把所有粗体都拉回来，这样你马上就会觉得设计更协调、更有意图。
>> 嗯。
>> 对。
>> 那接下来你准备怎么处理？好的，你已经有了新模块，对此很兴奋，那怎么把它整合回去呢？
>> 嗯，有几种方式。你可以右键点击，呃，让我实际操作一下。嗯，你可以把它复制为React组件。
>> 嗯。
>> 不过这是一种比较绕的方式。我可以把它导出为代码，然后粘贴到我的IDE里。你也可以直接让智能体拉取这个设计。
比如，我有Paper的代码库开着，但你可以直接说：请把我在Paper里选的这个做成代码库里的新组件，而实际上我们并不会在Paper里发布它。它可以读取我们刚才做的所有内容。
>> 嗯。
>> 而且它对我的代码库非常了解，因为它是我在用的智能体。所以，它能真正把这个设计融入进去，匹配我们的代码风格和约定，然后构建到代码库中。
如果这个组件已经存在，通常你已经有现成的，它就会直接更新，速度非常快。所以，我们看到很多人觉得这已经成为整个工作流程了。
甚至不再需要交接。就像一个单枪匹马的人在不断地修改、迭代和发布，真的很酷。
>> 是的，真酷。
>> 对，这就是它的强大之处。你知道，设计师现在比以往任何时候都更容易真正构建和发布他们想要的东西，真正实现最后一步，让作品上线并迭代优化。
让作品变得更好。我认为正是这样的工具赋予了人们超能力，这就像一个人能完成整个团队的工作。
>> 哦，当然，当然。而且我认为即使在团队中，我们也看到了很多这样的现象。团队利用这一点大大加快了速度，但我认为核心在于智能体工作流。
要用智能体完成工作，你需要能很好与它们对话的工具。这就是我们专注的方向。
>> YC下一期创业营现在开始接受申请。你心中有创业点子吗？到ycombinator.com/apply申请吧。申请永远不会太早，填写申请表会帮你完善你的想法。好了，回到视频。
好，再看一个？
来吧，再来看一个。
好，我们看到了 SciTechs。加速现场基础设施运维。规划流程，现场执行，并把每个行动变成活的知识库，你可以监控、自动化，甚至直接提问。好，我是说，
我第一眼注意到的，还是那个超级粗的大标题。
[笑声]
就像你说的，有一些光晕效果，配色感觉像是 vibe coding 的产物，又是很多紫色，这通常也是个标志。这里的动画看起来挺酷，有点像展示产品怎么工作。所以，
嗯，这确实引起了我的注意。
对，其实我到动画那里才大概明白这是干嘛的。
对，我还是不太确定，但看起来像是某种看板。
嗯，我感觉到它能让我以一种更容易监控的方式整理信息。我的设计反馈是，应该更清晰地告诉用户，我能从中得到什么。
有意思的是，下面有个正在播放的视频，里面是工程车和戴着安全帽的人在手机上操作。再结合上面的关键词，像是现场运维……
对，现场基础设施运维。所以能猜到这跟管理施工或重型机械相关。但首屏并不明显，因为最大的线索在首屏底部。
最大的线索就在折叠线下方。
我还想看到它到底能做什么，因为我已经有支持 AI 的看板了。那它针对施工有什么特别之处？我希望这部分能在页面上方作为价值主张体现出来。
但你说到一些基础问题，比如粗体在，看起来可能有些是 AI 生成的。这有个很好的例子：这个页面如果用更少的字体样式，会整洁很多。
你看，字号有四种。如果减到三种，会好看很多。我们快速试一下，我甚至可以让 AI 帮我们做。
我用 Paper 的截图功能从实际网站抓取，粘贴到 Paper 里变成可编辑图层，然后命名一下。还有另一种方式，你可以说这是什么。这是 SciTechs，这个就交给 Cursor 吧。
我们会说：“嘿，Cursor，请清理下这个 SciTechs 页面，最多用三种字号，不要加粗，所有文字用常规或更细的字重。”
所以你给那个模块命名了，还给 AI 提供了上下文线索。
对，这就是用不同方式告诉它该操作什么。我个人最喜欢的是留评论。我注意到之前跳转时，选择区域容易误触取消，所以留评论更稳妥。
你经常改变选择，我可能不小心取消。所以我很喜欢留评论的方式。好了，AI 开始处理这个了，它会去掉那些 vibe coded 的特征。
在 Paper 里，我们确实会告诉模型避免这些常见错误。人们经常问“你们的秘诀是什么？”为什么效果更好？为什么看起来更棒？
其实说白了，我们只是遵循了排版和对比度的基本规则。
嗯。
我们让团队里的资深设计师把他们的经验提炼成指令，然后……
这对模型来说很好。
是的，但即便如此，这本身也很强大。只需给模型的行为设置一些护栏，就能节省大量时间和精力。
是的，就像专家一样，稍微引导一下模型会非常有帮助。在现实生活中，我可能会手动完成，因为这样更快，但如果你有整个网站需要处理，
比如，使用代理（智能体）确实很有用。或者，当你完成后想将这部分集成回代码库，代理也能帮你做到。
这看起来已经是一个巨大的改进了。
是的，我觉得这都是一些很简单的改动，对吧？我们只是调整了字体的粗细，并统一了字号的数量。在我看来，这样看起来更有设计感，也更有意图。如果我们再调出原始版本，
就像，我们打开Paper并排比较一下。嗯，这有点主观，对吧？我知道可能有人在这个设计上花了不少时间，我认为他们内容做得很好，但
但通过消除这些AI痕迹，对我来说，右边那个感觉更值得信赖，更有意图，也更有设计感。
你谈到那些AI痕迹，这很有意思。
是的。
你见过的最常见的痕迹有哪些？当你看到某页或某个设计时，哪些线索让你觉得“某人只是把模型输出的东西直接用，然后称之为好，就完事了”？
首先，我认为不应该这样做。这很诱人，尤其是作为YC的创始人，你可能时间紧迫，正努力达成第一笔销售，所以很可能想直接用
云端生成的设计。但我不建议这么做，因为我觉得这并不能帮你脱颖而出。反而会让你看起来和其他无数项目一样，显得不够用心，不够在意。所以，我
认为设计是一个重要的差异化因素。看看过去一二十年的伟大公司，基本都有卓越的设计。我找不到反例。所以，我
认为如果你想成为那样伟大的公司，就必须在设计上投入心血，确保自己出类拔萃。至于AI痕迹，我们提到过字体和字号，这些都是大问题。
YC下一批申请现已开放。你心中有创业想法吗？请访问 ycombinator.com/apply 提交申请。永远不嫌早，填写申请表也会提升你的创意水平。好的，回到视频。
你可能见过那种在卡片侧面带有的小色条，像两像素宽的颜色。还有普遍过度使用卡片，到处都堆20个卡片。这些问题其实很容易修正。只需让代理，
比如让Paper创建20种布局变体，然后选出你最喜欢的一个。因为这样看起来会更有想法，而不是到处铺满卡片。你还有其他的例子吗？
紫色。
哦，紫色，是的。
渐变、大量图标，以及全大写的小标题。
小标题。
是的。你知道吗，很多都是为装饰而装饰的组件，并不是为了传达重要或有价值的信息，帮助用户理解设计意图。
它们的存在只是为了填充空间，很多都给人这种感觉。
这就像一个缺乏安全感的设计师。这些代理非常没有安全感，总想填充内容，所以到处都是小部件。”
对，没错。比如为什么要加那个？嗯，我也不知道。它看起来好像能让那些卡片的边角对齐得更好什么的，但真的能传达什么信息吗？那些数字有意义吗？没有吧。
那就直接删掉好了。
完全同意。我觉得设计很多时候就是做减法。
嗯。
这有点像……
先做复杂了再往回删是好事。但避免那种“AI味”的关键往往就是做减法。
当模型生成了一堆东西，你还得手动去改，比如看到标题觉得不对，你还得描述出来要怎么改，这很费劲。相比之下，如果你能直接选中它，按一下删除键……
对。
然后其他内容就自动调整好了。这样感觉掌控感强多了，而且把它打磨得更好所需的功夫也少得多。我觉得这特别强大，它不会逼着人为了质量去牺牲速度。
人们不用妥协于速度和效果，既能做出来很好看、很出彩的东西，也不会让人觉得是模型随便吐出来糊弄的。
有时候我们在想什么工具最合适，有时是提示词，有时是直接拖拽，你得用对工具，用不好可不行，对吧？所以……
每个用Vibe Coding做出来的应用都有浅色模式和深色模式。
[笑声]
而且这种东西在所有MVP、所有第一版里几乎都有。没人会把这种功能当成主打卖点吧。
对。
只不过它是白送的，模型很喜欢生成这个，所以大家都有。但它往往不值得我们花心思去做，也不一定需要在设计里体现出来。
而且它做得好不好呢？我觉得那种很差的深色模式也是一个很大的问题，比如它直接用了纯黑色，或者只是把颜色反转一下什么的。对了，Wes最近发了一条推文，展示了“天启四骑士”，哈哈，我们聊过的。
那条推文列出了四个AI生成设计的典型特征，你懂的。
对。
如果你有那个，基本可以删了，不需要。这个全大写的标签，可能也不需要。
还有那种额外的字距。
完全同意。
嗯哼。
对。这不就是我14岁学设计时的样子嘛，觉得“哇，拉大字号间距，太好看了”。还有这个，带小图标的徽章，也是典型。
对。
好多药丸形状的按钮，好多图标啊。
是啊，当然还有那个紫渐变。你知道，Linear把这个风格做得很棒，我觉得后来就被模型学去了。
对，有意思的是，这些元素单独看并不差。问题在于用得太多，到处都是，就像你说的，就不突出了。
嗯。
看起来还很粗糙。设计一直在变，标准一直在变，底线也在不断提高，你得始终走在前面。不然就看着很普通。
普通的东西就不出众，人们也没兴趣用。
我觉得如果对外展示很平庸，就很难做成一家伟大的公司。
这甚至影响你招人，影响你吸引什么样的人才。所以，值得用心去打造。
好，我们来看看这个Maridata。像当地人一样扫码支付。一个全球钱包，可以在亚洲和拉丁美洲解锁本地扫码支付。嗯，这里有一堆国旗，我觉得是表示覆盖很多国家。
嗯，这是支付相关的东西。我有点紧张。一个支付产品，看起来像是随便用AI堆出来的。
是的，品牌可信度很重要，尤其是涉及金融的时候。这里又是一个例子，把内容放上来，好内容放在首屏。我还挺喜欢这个网站的活力，
虽然有些地方有点太野了，太乱了，有点糙。但能看出它想传达一种全球感，我觉得挺酷的。
在我们……哇，我爱这个“如何运作”的部分。
对，这个不错。
把这个也放上去。你知道，我滑了很久才看到这里。
对，这个看起来干净多了，也更专业。
确实。
这也让我更信任它。
完全同意。所以，在上节目之前，我快速用Paper试了一下，我只是让它把这个网站回退一下，为它建立一个更专业、更可信的基础。
更有信任感。我们用5.5版本做的，结果就是这个。实际上我觉得，在这个案例里，它丢失了一些原设计的兴奋感。
嗯。
但这就是你使用设计工具的原因，你可以自己再把那种感觉带回来。
对。
但我确实觉得这给了你一个更好的基础。不过还是，文字太多了。
确实。
文字太多了。
有些地方可以收一收。
嗯，但我觉得这能给你多一点基础。而且，你可以进来删掉一些“氛围感”生成的东西。少即是多。这个网站我想做的就是保持那种兴奋感。
那种国际化的感觉。
嗯哼。
像这样，很独特。但你不能太过了，比如这个文字渐变可能有点太花哨，让人不太信服。但我确实喜欢它的价值主张，而且我很快就能明白它是什么。
大部分情况下很快就能理解，我喜欢这点。
我喜欢他们在右下角放了个二维码。
这也是产品的一部分，对吧？就像……
对。
这很酷，我以前很少见到这种设计。
这让我想互动，很有吸引力。
嗯。
嗯。整体感觉和氛围是——如果我们能让它更可信一点，但我喜欢这种兴奋感、这种能量，还有这种邀请的感觉。
对，但那个角落太容易被忽略了，因为你习惯了右下角是聊天框，你会觉得那里有一堆可以忽略的东西。
（笑声）
除非有问题，你才会看那里。也许他们应该把二维码移到更显眼的地方，说“现在试试”。
放在主视觉区域里。
对对。
我觉得这个主视觉可以发挥更大作用，因为当我往下滚动时，我会觉得“嗯，不错，挺扎实的。”越往下看越觉得可信。
嗯，你的观点很有趣，就是说，当你用模型生成设计时，最终是模型在设计，你有点受制于它们的训练数据和设计偏好。
它们被训练的方式，以及它们喜欢怎么设计。
对，没错。
所以重要的是用对模型，而且这些模型会随着时间推移在设计上越来越好。然后你需要的是更快速的控制。
>> 对。
所以，拥有那种控制力，能够编辑它，让它更符合你自己的愿景，这其实是真正缺失的关键部分，我认为这正是 Paper 现在所提供的大部分价值。
智能体可以加速你的工作，节省大量精力，比如帮你做翻译或调整尺寸之类的任务。但我们坚信设计中的“人”的元素，以及它的重要性。所以我们正努力
打造一个工具，让人类能与智能体高效协作。
你觉得智能体能不能学会品味？
[笑声]
能吗？
它们会在字距等一些微观的技术细节上越来越强。
>> 嗯。
呃，随着时间推移。而且让我感到鼓舞的是，像 Fable 这样的模型似乎更有思考力。
>> 嗯哼。
感觉它在做决定时，真的做了些思考和权衡，比之前的模型强。所以我觉得这就是设计的一部分——那份深思熟虑。
>> 对。
呃，那我会不会觉得它会取代人类来做这些设计决策？不，绝不可能。因为设计中很大一部分其实是组织中非常人性化的决策过程。
>> 嗯哼。
比如，给人们看设计方案，然后他们会说‘哦，不是这样的，我不喜欢’。设计最终呈现的是像素，但其在组织中的作用是关于决策、利益相关者、整合需求与问题空间，而这些智能体其实并不擅长。你懂吧，谁知道以后会怎样，它们会越来越聪明，但我觉得人类是构建脱颖而出作品不可或缺的一环。
引入需求和问题空间，这些并不是智能体真正擅长的事情。你知道，随着时间推移，它们会变得越来越聪明，但我仍然认为人类是做出突出产品必不可少的元素。
在创造与众不同的东西时，人类是不可或缺的核心。
>> 是的，有意思。我和一位在某个数十亿美元、以设计为导向的公司负责设计的人有过类似的对话。我们在讨论人类头脑中不断进行的思维过程，比如对事物的反应、评估标准，这些对我们来说非常内隐。而问题在于，你能不能把这些东西说出来？
他们正在评估的标准，对我们人类而言非常内隐。问题是，你能不能把这些东西明确说出来？
>> 嗯哼。
比如，[清嗓子] 你决定某物好不好、看起来如何，或者
非常主观。
是否达到标准的过程，你能不能真的去量化并教给模型，直到它拥有像人类一样的品味？然后问题就变成了，如果所有模型都能做到这一点，那一切是不是又会变得千篇一律？
也就是说，如果所有模型都能达到那种品味，那所有东西是不是又会看起来一样了？
>> [笑声]
而且你总是需要人类去发掘真正新颖、出众、能突破极限的下一个事物。
我们看到，即使在人类预训练模型中，当趋势占主导时也会出现这种情况。你知道，每个人都有一段时间看起来像是线性的，然后其他人又发现了新东西，对吧？我确实认为模型会擅长战术。
它们会逐渐不再把所有东西都加粗。你知道，我觉得那很棒，那会很好。但仅仅是想法、产品，设计中有太多像“这是否正确展示价值”的问题，那更重要。
比如这个网站，我觉得有点过于夸张，也许对他们来说，做得非常有趣和令人兴奋非常重要。也许这正是他们市场所需要的。
>> 嗯。
你知道，所以也许对他们来说，更高级的事情是变得非常令人兴奋，并且有点模型化。
决策，你懂的，也许有了足够的信息，你就能开始做到那一点，但我觉得我们离那还很远。是啊，也许十年左右吧。也许我不知道，也许我太悲观了。也许会更快到来。
但我仍然认为人类是其中不可或缺的一部分。
>> 是的，我们当然希望如此。
>> 是的，希望如此。[笑声]
我很好奇，你们在Paper内部是如何使用智能体的？
在某些方面我们用得很多，但在其他方面我们有点像恐龙。比如，我们在Slack里没有智能体，也没有……我们在编码方面用得不少，但我们仍然会阅读我们的代码。
我们阅读所有代码，每一行。
>> 每一行。
通常会有多个人类阅读每一行代码。
>> 为什么？
嗯，一方面是因为设计工具很难构建。你知道，在今天，你无法写出像Figma那样水平的设计工具代码。也许最终能做到，但这需要大量精确、细致的工作。这些系统非常复杂，我们就必须非常小心。我们要确保我们的体验，你知道，设计师需要120帧每秒，必须得快，每次都得可靠。而智能体还达不到。
系统方面，所以我们得非常小心。我们要确保我们的体验，你知道，设计师需要120帧每秒，必须得快，每次都得可靠。而智能体还达不到。
>> 还没有。
另外，我们是一支小而精的团队，对吧？12个人，保持极高的人才标准。我觉得在公司建设上，这些天就应该这样做。用智能体来加速人员的工作。
但如果人更少，沟通负担就更小，其他成本也更低。我们使用智能体的一个例子是我们的品牌设计师Agu。他是一位才华横溢的品牌设计师，擅长视觉。他会一点代码，但我不认为他会称自己为程序员。在上次发布前，他大约用了一周时间就做出了我们的整个网站。
视觉方面，他会一点代码，但我认为他不会称自己为程序员。他大约用了一周时间就做出了我们的整个网站。
>> 哇。
>> 包括上线和所有的动画效果。他所有的设计都是在 Paper 上完成的。这种设计你是不会想通过提示词去做的，对吧？他背景里还有着色器。
这些图案若有若无地透出来。他先在 Paper 里完成所有设计，然后才用提示词。这是大约6个月前的事了，当时模型不一样。他就是在 Paper 文件上加上动画提示词。
他说，“把我的设计转成代码，这是个 Next.js 网站，帮我弄好。”其他人都没参与，所以 Agu 在一周内就完成了从设计到实现。因为他是设计师，他还埋了彩蛋。
彩蛋，还有一些小惊喜。
>> 而且全部都是互动的。
>> 这些互动效果，是他以前不可能做到的。他以前没时间做这些。虽然技术上肯定能达到，但就是没时间。所以我觉得这真的很棒。
>> 很多时候，这种应用并不在我们的核心产品里，核心产品还是需要精确的，还是以人为主。但在其他方面，比如我们要做的所有视频、营销网站等等这些内容上，
我们可以让智能体帮忙，让人们更快地完成这些工作。
>> 是的，我们确实做了不少这种工作。当然还有编码智能体，我们大量使用 Cursor 和 Cloud Code，还用 bug bot 来做 PR 审查，这真的很有用。虽然有时候它有点吹毛求疵，
但还是能抓出 bug，这是好事。现在对于智能体，大家都有点 FOMO，好像觉得每家公司都能不检查代码就上线，你是不是太慢了？
我们倾向于认为，高质量的软件需要花费时间。
>> 嗯。
>> 我们的竞争对手有各种功能，但他们没有专注度，或者人们根本不在乎。而且无论出于什么原因，人们就是希望 Paper 能更好，不希望那些功能全的竞争对手胜出。
我觉得这是因为我们用心了，我们在精准和细节上投入了关怀。所以即使我们慢一点，人们还是更在意我们的产品，所以我认为质量很重要。幸好如此。
>> 我和很多设计师聊过，感觉你们几乎在掀起一股潮流，像一场信徒运动，大家现在都觉得用 Paper 是新酷的事情，很多设计师都在用。
>> 这是一种新的现代工作方式。这是你们有意为之的吗？你们在吸引用户、增长、获取关注度方面做了什么？感觉你们已经是少数几家能跟 Figma 抗衡的公司了，显然 Figma 已经是个巨无霸并且上市了，财富500强都在用他们。
>> 但感觉你们已经开始打破这种局面了，至少在特定用户群中。你们是怎么做到的？什么方法最有效？
>> 你们是如何执行的，哪些策略最成功？
>> 是的，很大一部分原因是我们的价值观与市场高度一致。我们第一年没有产品，但通过谈论价值观就积累了大约2.5万的推特粉丝。就是上播客说“我真的很喜欢设计，你喜欢设计吗？”然后我们就开始聊排版或者别的什么。
上播客说“我真的很喜欢设计，你喜欢设计吗？”如果价值观和用户契合，他们会原谅你产品上的很多不足，甚至愿意等你去完善。
他们会等着你，只要他们认为你是真诚的，就会为你加油。特别是做设计软件，这真的很重要。也许不是所有软件都这样，但设计软件，通常最好的产品、最真诚的产品会赢。
>> 所以我们只是12个人的设计师和工程师团队，我们践行我们的价值观，人们很认同。顺便说一句，我们的产品也非常好，我觉得这部分也很重要。你必须做到。
>> 产品确实好，这一点很重要，你必须要达到。但我觉得这只是其中一部分。然后还有市场时机。每一家公司，希望我们将来也能遇到这种问题吧……
>> 每家公司最终都会向高端市场进军，但那样你就没那么酷了，对吧？你卖给企业客户，就不再做那些地下的酷玩活动了。所以我很荣幸我们能成为社区的一部分。
>> 要说社区，我想你看到了，Ramp 在信用卡实际订阅数据上发布了消息。没错。如果他们还发布了可以对话的 AI，询问 Ramp 数据的情况。如果……
你问设计工具，呃，你知道的，显然是Figma。Sketch也在那儿。然后Paper跟Sketch并驾齐驱。所以我们是Figma出现以来，第一家在这个市场有所突破的公司，你
知道吗？它增长非常快。嗯，这真的很鼓舞人心。很激动，因为当你创业的时候，你不知道它会怎么发展。你毫无头绪。就像我说的，有几个月我都在想没人会在意这个。
>> [笑声]
>> 而现在有这么多酷的人，嗯，比我酷多了，他们非常在意Paper，还穿着我们的周边什么的，看着真开心。说实话，这是最棒的部分。
>> 那真的很酷。这不是你的第一家公司。这是你的第二家公司，对吧？嗯，看起来甚至在你没有产品之前，你就已经把自己推出去，你的愿景和价值观，你成为了
大使，这就是人们在你有产品之前所认同的，当然在产品早期也是，而成功的因素就是你。嗯，你把那些推出去。那这跟你
之前创办另一家公司有什么不同？对比一下两者？
>> 嗯，我的第一家公司叫Modules，做设计和开发者交接的。
>> 嗯哼。
>> 我们中途做了Radix UI。那算是我们的一个副业项目，结果就一直做下去了。你知道，Radix成了默认的React组件库了。
>> 一个是这是在AI之前。所以，你知道，一切都更难。设计和开发交接更难。二是我们真的同时听取双方意见，结果搞糊涂了。因为设计师想让工程师改变，工程师想让设计师改变。
变化，他们会告诉你对方的团队会使用你的软件，你不能这样开发软件。因此我们学到了一些关于如何打造人们真正想要的东西的艰难教训。而且，我想我已经能够
在Paper上应用这些教训。但是，我们确实做到了，我的意思是，Radix有惊人的产品市场契合度。我们只是没有看到围绕它建立一个风险规模业务的方法。所以我们想，就让它免费，把它赠送出去，然后
你知道，下次再带着新东西回来。那很酷，效果非常好。我们把这家公司卖给了WorkOS，那是一家出色的认证和身份公司。我们用WorkOS来支持Paper。而且
几年之后，我想再次投入创意工具的开发。
>> 那你从那段经历中学到了哪些教训，现在打算应用呢？
>> 你可能会过度复杂化产品构建。你知道，‘做人们想要的东西’是个很棒的说法。很多时候你带着你的产品，会想：我的公司接下来需要什么？现在对我的公司来说，可能发生的
最好的事情是什么？对我们来说，一开始就是参与对话，拥有Twitter粉丝。那么，去做那些能获得Twitter粉丝的事情吧。我们去上播客，和用户交流，然后
外在代表他们的价值观。所以，很多时候实际上很简单。我觉得我们把它搞得太复杂了，试图为公司制定那些出色的战略，实际上就是问自己你接下来需要什么，然后做最
直接了当的事情来达成目标。而且，不要害怕去做听起来很难的事情，显然你必须得做。所以，这就是我们采取的理念，瓶颈优先，我非常相信这个理念。
对我们来说，现在的瓶颈是早期采用者正在使用Paper。而那些可能不是早期采用者的人已经习惯了他们现在的做法，他们缺少诸如此类的功能，比如评论
和组件。所以现在我们的瓶颈实际上又回到了功能上。因此，那就是我们接下来要做的，然后释放这个瓶颈给业务。另一个战术性的做法是
每天和用户交流。这非常重要。在公司成立的第一年，我给自己定了个规矩，每天必须和一位设计师交谈，我坚持了一整年。这非常有用，因为我学会了
当你开始创建公司和产品时，你会有不同的视角。你不可避免会带有个人知识。所以，保持与用户的对话根深蒂固地联系在一起真的很重要。
是的，随着公司成长和规模扩大，这变得越来越难，因为有太多事情在争夺你的时间，把你拉向不同的方向，它们看起来都很重要，或者此刻很紧急。
此刻确实如此。但真正核心的是那些最基本的事情：打造你的产品，与用户交流，以及锻炼或做任何你需要做的事情，以免在专注前两件事时发疯。但这就是公司的核心所在。
在公司存续期间都是如此。很高兴听到你从第一天起就这么做了，我相信这现在已经深深地植入了你们团队的文化中。
>> 是的。
>> 并且现在每个人都在和用户交流。
>> 哦是的。是的，当新人加入时，我们会说，你必须得在Discord或Slack里和人们聊天。这真的非常重要。不是每个人都能适应。也许他们来自一个更大的公司，在那里他们被告知不能和用户交谈，但在这里，不，你得进去。你不会搞砸的。而且你会学到很多。我认为这会指导你的决策。
你的决策在公司中非常重要。你可以看看那些成功的公司，你可以追溯他们的决策，比如“哦，那是一个转折点”，“那个决策非常好”。所以我认为让员工了解情况是很重要的。
因为我无法做出公司里的每一个决策。即使只有12个人，我也不可能做到。所以如果你能让员工非常了解用户以及他们真正想要什么，那么好的决策就会到处产生。这非常重要。
让员工掌握充分的信息，因为我不可能在公司里做每一个决定，即使只有12个人我也做不到。所以，如果员工能真正了解用户及其需求，那么好的决策就会层出不穷。这真的很重要。
员工了解用户想要什么，公司就会到处做出好决策。这确实非常重要。
>> 你认为设计的下一步是什么？
>> 嗯，我认为很多设计并没有改变。同样，在组织中，设计的功能仍然非常重要，作为探索问题空间、竞争分析、向高管和利益相关者沟通的方式，这些都没变。所以我们根本没看到这方面的变化。我认为设计的功能会继续存在。如果说有什么变化，那就是我们会看到更多的设计需求，因为公司更多了，需要做的软件也更多了。
我们看到世界上对设计的需求越来越多。我确实认为工具会加速发展，因为我们需要能够保持高质量，以跟上工程和产品团队的速度。软件会按时交付，不管设计师有没有机会让它变得更好。这就是竞争格局的现实。所以，我们如何确保设计师能参与对话并跟上交付的节奏？
所以，我们看到设计需求在不断增长。我认为工具会加速，因为我们得跟上工程和产品团队的速度。不管设计师有没有机会改进，软件都会发布。但现实就是这样。所以，我们如何帮助设计师参与进对话，跟上发布过程？
但我认为，有时候变化并没有人们想的那么多，因为很多设计都涉及人的问题，最终的像素只是过程的输出。
设计师能参与对话并跟上流程。但总的来说，我认为有时候变化并没有人们想的那么多，因为很多设计是非常人性化的问题，最终的像素只是过程的输出。
设计是一个非常人性化的问题，最终的界面只是过程的输出。
>> 最终它是一种媒介，对吧？
>> 没错。是的。
>> 那么Paper的下一步是什么？
>> 嗯，就像我说的，我们正在构建一些基础功能，比如组件、评论、瓶颈消除。我非常兴奋。从用户交流中学到的是，人们到处在建立各种原型，它们最终放在Vercel上或作为HTML文件，人们不知道如何给它们留反馈，甚至不知道哪个是别人正在讨论的。所以我们要做的是，基本上你可以把东西iframe到Paper画布上，作为整理原型的地方，然后人们可以像平时那样在原型上留下评论。所以当人们问我们是否在做原型工具时，我们说是的，有点类似。我们会帮你整理原型，并有反馈循环。
人们到处建立原型，它们放在Vercel或HTML文件中，但没人知道如何评论或找到别人讨论的那个。所以我们要做的是，你可以把东西iframe到Paper画布上，作为整理原型的空间，然后人们可以像往常一样评论。所以当人们问我们是否在做原型工具时，我们说是的，类似。我们会帮你整理原型并提供反馈周期。
基本上你可以把原型嵌入到Paper画布上，作为整理和评论的地方。所以，这有点像在做原型工具，但主要是帮他们整理和反馈。我认为这对那些为设计师提供环境让他们随意编码的公司来说是一个重要的解锁，但结果很混乱，他们需要工具来整理。
它有点像原型工具，我们会帮你整理原型并建立反馈循环。我认为这对那些正在为设计师创造环境来自由编码的公司来说是个重大解锁，但结果杂乱，他们需要帮助整理的工具。所以这是未来六个月我们重点解决的问题。
设计师们可以在其中自由发挥编码，但结果很混乱，他们需要一些工具来组织。所以，这将是未来六个月左右我们要重点做的事情。
这是大家预期中的基本要求。
>> 太棒了。史蒂文，非常感谢你来到我们节目，分享Paper以及你多年来积累的设计洞见，这些经验来之不易，来自于你创立的公司和那些令人惊叹的工作经历。真的非常感谢。
>> 是的，非常感谢你们的邀请。
>> 这就是本期《设计评论》的全部内容，我们下期再见。